GERALDO RIVERA, BRIAN KILMEADE,
DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
LET'S RECAP MIKE POMPEO'S
CONFIRMATION HEARING.
IF YOU WANT TO BE PART OF THE
REPUBLICAN ADMINISTRATION,
PLEASE DENOUNCE THE REPUBLICAN
ADMINISTRATION.
>> IT'S FAIR FOR OUR MEMBERS TO
ASK WHETHER YOUR RELATIONSHIP IS
ROOTED IN A CANDID, HEALTHY,
GIVE AND TAKE DYNAMIC OR WHETHER
IT'S BASED ON DEFERENTIAL
WILLINGNESS TO GO ALONG TO GET
ALONG.
>> Greg: UP NEXT, SHAMELESS
BIGOTRY SMEARS.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY VIEWS OF THE
MUSLIM FAITH OR PEOPLE WHO
BELIEVE IN WORSHIPING OTHER
GODS.
IS THAT SOMETHING NEGATIVE IN
OUR COUNTRY?
>> Greg: LET'S NOT FORGET THE
T WORD.
>> CAN YOU CLARIFY FOR ME HOW
YOU WOULD COME AS SECRETARY OF
STATE, BE CLEAR AS TO AMERICA'S
COMMITMENT AGAINST TORTURE.
>> Greg: SO PREDICTABLE, SO
FAKE SO IRRELEVANT.
MIKE DID FINE UNTIL THIS.
>> WITH RESPECT TO BUILDING A
TEAM OUT OF THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, THIS IS
SOMETHING I'VE DONE MULTIPLE
TIMES IN MY LIFE.
I DID IT AS A TANK PLATOON
LEADER.
I DID IT AS A CAVALRY TROOP.
I DO IT FOR TWO SMALL BUSINESSES
IN KANSAS.
AND I WORKED HARD AT IT.
I WILL LEAVE OTHERS TO JUDGE THE
SUCCESS.
>> Greg: OH, DEAR.
PLATOON LEADER?
THE LANGUAGE OF WAR?
DOES CHUCK SCHUMER HAVE TRAUMA
COUNSELORS STANDING BY.
I HOPE CORY BOOKER BROUGHT HIS
COMFORT BONNIE.
HOW DO YOU KNOW POMPEO DESERVES
THE GOOD?
>> PLEASE REMOVE.
>> Greg: SHE TOTALLY NAILED IT
IT.
POMPEO ISN'T A DIPLOMAT.
THAT SHOULD BE ON HIS BUSINESS
CARD.
WHEN YOU REDUCE PEOPLE TO
GIBBERING FOOLS, YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE A WINNER.
SEE THIS TWEET FROM AL GORE.
SENATORS SHOULD REJECT MIKE
POMPEO.
HE DENIES THE CLIMATE CRISIS AND
HAS BEEN DOING THE BIDDING FOR
FOSSIL FUEL INTERESTS HIS WHOLE
CAREER.
WELL, GORE DOES NO FOSSILS.
HE'S ABOUT AS UP-TO-DATE ON
WORLD EVENTS AS FRED FLINTSTONE.
AGAIN, IF AL IS A "NO," POMPEO
IS A "YES."
HERE'S ANOTHER.
OVER 180 NATIONAL ORGS COVERING
ISSUES FOR NATIONAL SECURITY AND
WOMEN'S HEALTH TO CLIMATE CHANGE
AND HUMAN RIGHTS HAVE PUBLICLY
OPPOSED POMPEO.
#StopPompeo.
UNLIKE THOSE GROUPS, POMPEO IS
NO PACIFIST.
ASK ISIS IF YOU CAN STILL FIND
THEM.
WITHOUT NONPACIFIST, PACIFISTS
WOULD BE BONES UNDER A
DICTATOR'S BOOT.
IT'S EASY TO BE A HOLY MAN ON A
MOUNTAIN OR ON CAPITOL HILL BUT
IN THE REAL WORLD, THINGS ARE
MORE DANGEROUS.
DIPLOMAT IS NICE BUT A REALIST
IS BETTER.
WE NEED POMPEO, NOT DEEPAK
CHOPRA.
WE NEED TO FLOW FROM A GROWN-UP.
THAT IS POMPEO.
NO WONDER THE LEFT CAN'T STAND
HIM.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO AROUND THE
TABLE AND ASK WHAT CAUGHT YOUR
EYE.
WE WILL PROBABLY SKIP
BRIAN KILMEADE BECAUSE HE WAS
SLEEPING ALL DAY.
DANA, HE TOUCHED ON THE MORALE
PROBLEM.
>> Dana: HE'S NOT A DIPLOMAT.
WHEN HE WAS FIRST IN THE
MILITARY, HE TALKED ABOUT BEING
AT THE BERLIN WALL WHEN IT CAME
DOWN AND THAT HIS GREAT RESPECT
WAS FROM THE DIPLOMATS FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT WORKING WITH
EVERYONE DISSOLVABLE WAS A
DIFFICULT POLITICAL SITUATION.
THEN HE SAID HE RECOGNIZES, HE
SPENT TIME AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT, THAT MORALE THERE IS
ABYSMAL AND THAT WOULD BE HIS
FIRST PRIORITY TO TRY TO FIX.
IF YOU CARED ABOUT THAT OR THAT
WAS ONE OF THE COMPLAINTS THAT
LEFT OUT ABOUT REX TILLERSON,
THE LEFT IS GOING TO END UP WITH
THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
IT'S GOING TO BE SECRETARY
POMPEO.
WHEN HE GETS CONFIRMED.
IF YOU WANT TO HOLD HIM TO
SOMETHING, MAKE SURE THAT MORALE
AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT IS
SOMETHING YOU KEEP KNOCKING ON
HIS DOOR ABOUT.
>> Greg: GERALDO, YOU ARE A
REPUBLICAN BUT YOU'RE KIND OF A
HAWK.
YOU ARE PROMILITARY.
DO YOU GET THE SENSE OF WHEN YOU
WATCH THESE COMMITTEES THAT
DEMOCRATS KIND OF LIVE IN A
WORLD WHERE THE ONLY -- THEY
ONLY SEE OUR ACTIONS AS
BELLICOSE AND THEY SEE THE
OPPOSITION OF SOME KIND OF
AMORPHOUS I DON'T KNOW THING OUT
THERE.
>> Geraldo: IT'S A HIGHLY
PHILOSOPHICAL QUESTION.
I WOULD RATHER DIRECT MY
ATTENTION TO MY POMPEO.
I >> Greg: YOU SHOULD HAVE SET
I WILL HAVE MY TEAM GET BACK TO
YOU.
>> Geraldo: I LOVE THAT HE
GRADUATED FIRST AT WEST POINT.
I LOVE THE HARVARD LAW SCHOOL
BUSINESS.
IN TERMS OF PERSONAL STYLE,
CHARISMA, HE IS A MUCH MORE
NATURAL FIT WITH DONALD TRUMP
THAN REX TILLERSON WAS.
I THINK HE WILL BE FINE.
AS HAWKISH AS I MAY BE, I THINK
POMPEO IS TO THE RIGHT OF ME.
I THINK HE IS MORE LIKE
JOHN BOLTON.
I THINK YOU CAN CONSIDER HE AND
BOLTON TOGETHER AS A WAR
CABINET.
BUT I ALSO THINK THAT WARRIORS,
AND HE'S AN ARMY VET, WARRIORS
ARE LESS LIKELY TO SLIP INTO WAR
THEN PACIFISTS.
>> Greg: SO TRUE.
KIMBERLY, GIVE ME YOUR THOUGHTS
AND TRY TO MAKE IT ABOUT
7 MINUTES LONG SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO TALK TO KILMEADE.
>> Kimberly: IT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT TO DO ANYTHING AGAINST
HIM.
IF YOU CAN BE THE HEAD OF THE
CIA, HOW ARE YOU UNFIT TO SERVE
IN THIS POSITION.
HE'S GOT A GREAT RECORD.
I AGREE WITH YOU, GERALDO, HE'S
A GOOD PERSONAL FIT WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
HE TRUSTS HIM, HE LIKES HIM.
THEY ARE ABLE TO WORK WELL
TOGETHER.
I THINK HE ALREADY HAS NOW THE
BENEFIT OF THE EXPERIENCE OF
RUNNING CIA.
IF YOU CAN BE TRUSTED WITH
SECRET INTELLIGENCE ORGANIZATION
AND YOU'VE DONE VERY WELL THERE
TO THE POINT WHERE HE TRUSTS YOU
FOR THIS NEXT POSITION THAT'S
ALSO INTEGRAL TO THE SUCCESS OF
LOT.
ON WHAT GROUNDS OTHER THAN
POLITICAL, STALLING, OR TRYING
TO BE OBSTRUCTIONIST, ARE THEY
GOING TO SAY HE'S UNFIT OR
UNSUITABLE FOR THIS POSITION?
HOW MANY MINUTES DID I KILL?
>> Greg: WE ALMOST MADE IT.
KILMEADE, WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS, IF YOU HAVE THOUGHTS.
HERE'S WHAT I THINK.
HE IS FINALLY GETTING HIS BAND
TOGETHER.
THEY RESPECT HIM ENOUGH TO
DISAGREE WITH HIM PRIVATELY AND
NOT CALL
1-800-"WASHINGTON POST."
WHAT POMPEO HAS DONE IS
ESTABLISHED, THE RAPPORT,
NATIONAL SECURITY.
THE MEETINGS SHE HAS WITH MY
POMPEO, AND WHEN POMPEO IS NOT
THERE, HE GOES TO GINA HASPEL
WHO'S HOPEFULLY GOING TO BE
HEADING UP THE CIA SHORTLY.
GIVE HIM IT COMES TO MIND US
CORY BOOKER WANTS TO MAKE SURE
HE HAS FOR SAME-SEX MARRIAGE
WHICH IS A PRETTY INTERESTING
QUESTION FOR THE SECRETARY OF
STATE.
EMPTY THE ARSENAL.
CORY BOOKER IS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT EVERY MINUTE OF THE
DAY, EVEN AT 2:00 IN THE
AFTERNOON ON THURSDAY.
MY HOPE WAS RAND PAUL WHO MAKES
SO MUCH SENSE SOMETIMES WOULD
MAKE A LITTLE MORE SENSE THIS
TIME.
WHAT I WOULD RATHER IS HE COME
OUT AND SAY WHY HAVEN'T WE LEFT
AFGHANISTAN OR WHY DO WE HAVE
THE WAR IN IRAQ?
HE WAS AN EYE DOCTOR MAKING SURE
EVERYONE'S PUPILS WERE DILATED
AND WE WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF
DEALING WITH SADDAM HUSSEIN.
TO COME BACK IN 2018 AND MAKE
HIM DISAVOW HIS SUPPORT OF THE
IRAQ WAR WAS FARCICAL.
I THINK, I HOPE DEMOCRATS CAN
UNDERSTAND HOW QUALIFIED HE IS
AND START TO UNDERSTAND, START
TO VOTE YES.
>> Greg: THAT WAS A CHEAP SHOT
AGAINST EYE DOCTORS.
>> Brian: YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT'S TRUE.
I AM AGAINST LENSCRAFTERS
BECAUSE I HAD A BAD EXPERIENCE.
>> Geraldo: IN REGARD TO WHAT
I SAID ABOUT HAWKS BEING LESS
LIKELY TO DECLARE WAR, IT COULD
BE AMBASSADOR BOLTON AND CIA
DIRECTOR POMPEO WHO ARE HOLDING
THE PRESIDENT BACK ON WHAT WOULD
BE A GRATUITOUS STRIKE AT THIS
POINT IN COLD BLOOD AGAINST
SYRIA.
IT'S FRAUGHT WITH PERIL.
THE UPSIDE IS SO NARROW.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU DEFINE WHAT
YOU HIT.
30 BOMBS, 60 BOMBS, 300 BOMBS?
>> Kimberly: THINKING ABOUT IT
MORE CAREFULLY.
>> Brian: I COULD NOT DISAGREE
WITH YOU ANYMORE.
GERALDO, WE KNOW WHERE THE
MILITARY SITES ARE.
WE KNOW WHERE THEY MAKE THE
CHEMICAL WEAPONS.
GETTING OUR GUYS IN PLACE,
GETTING OUR PEOPLE IN PLACE TO
TAKE OUT THE SITES.
IT'S NOT KILL EVERYBODY.
IT'S WIPE OUT THEIR ABILITY TO
MAKE THIS.
>> Geraldo: IS A POSSIBLE BY A
CRUISE MISSILE STRIKE --
YOU NEED A BATHTUB IN THREE
DRUGS OF VARIOUS CHEMICALS.
>> Brian: I LIKE ARI
FLEISCHER'S IDEA OF TAKING OUT
HIS PALACE.
>> Geraldo: THE PRESIDENT'S
INSTINCT TO GET OUT OF SYRIA IS
THE CORRECT INSTINCT.
WE BACKED THE WRONG SIDE AND
THEN CONFLICT.
THE DANGER TO THE UNITED STATES
AND THE FREE WORLD, THE SUNNI
MUSLIM EXTREMISM.
WE ARE ON THE WRONG SIDE IN
SYRIA.
THE SOONER WE GET OUT, THE
BETTER.
>> Brian: WHO IS CHEERING THE
LOUDEST, RUSSIA OR IRAN?
>> Geraldo: THEY ARE IN ORBIT,
AN AXIS OF EVIL, BUT I DON'T
CARE.
LET THEM BE AS EVIL AS THEY WANT
TO BE.
LET THEM SHARE BLINTZES AND
HUMMUS.
I DON'T CARE.
>> Greg: LET'S HEAR FROM
POMPEO.
>> Dana: WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE?
>> Greg: WHO TOOK AWAY JUAN
AND THE GUY WITH THE FUNNY HAIR?
>> WE HAVE THE PRIMARY MISSION
WE'VE BEEN ENGAGED INTO DEFEAT
ISIS.
WE DID SO USING A GROUP OF MEN
WHO DID GREAT WORK, AND WE TOOK
THE CALIPHATE DOWN.
WE OUGHT TO BE PROUD OF IT.
THERE IS STILL WORK TO DO.
THE OTHER OBJECTIVE IS TO
ACHIEVE A DIV MEDIC OUTCOME SUCH
THAT THERE IS MORE STABILITY.
WE CAN TAKE DOWN THE VIOLENCE
AND THIS IS A DIPLOMATIC TASK.
SO THAT WE GET TO A PLACE WHERE
THE SYRIAN PEOPLE CAN ULTIMATELY
GOVERN THEMSELVES.
OUR GOAL IS TO MAKE THAT A
POST-ASSAD SYRIA.
>> Greg: YOU HEARD CROSS FIRE
RIGHT HERE.
AFTER HEARING THAT CAN ALREADY
SEE IT?
WHERE DO YOU FALL?
BETWEEN THOSE GUYS.
>> Dana: EILEEN A LITTLE BIT
KILMEADE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS RIGHT TO
CRITICIZE PRESIDENT OBAMA.
EVEN MADELEINE ALBRIGHT
CRITICIZED PRESIDENT OBAMA FOR
THE REDLINE HE PUT IN PLACE
WHICH LED TO THE SITUATION
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TRYING TO
FIX.
BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO DREW A
REDLINE.
IT WAS A YEAR AGO THAT HE THREW
A LITTLE MISSILE ASSAD'S WAY.
DIDN'T DO ENOUGH TO DECAPITATE.
WE DON'T HAVE A POLITICAL
SOLUTION.
THERE'S NOT A GREAT STRATEGY BUT
HE'S ALREADY BEEN, NOW HE'S AT
RISK OF NOT ENFORCING HIS OWN
NEW REDLINE.
>> Geraldo: HOW ABOUT A
BLOCKADE, ECONOMIC SANCTIONS,
SEIZING EVERY DOLLAR SYRIA HAS
DEPOSITED IN EVERY U.K. AND USA
BANK?
>> Dana: GREAT.
>> Geraldo: WHEN YOU TAKE A
LOOK UNILATERAL MILITARY
ACTION --
>> Brian: YOU HAVE FRANCE AND
ENGLAND, SAUDI ARABIA.
>> Geraldo: SINGH FRANCE STEP
UP TO THE PLATE, OKAY.
>> Kimberly: MIGHT NOT BE
ABOUT, IN TERMS OF SUPPLYING THE
MILITARY MIGHT, THE
UNITED STATES IS CAPABLE AND
OFTEN CARRIES THE LOAD WITH THAT
BUT IF YOU HAVE SOME KIND OF
INTERNATIONAL COALITION OR
SUPPORT WHERE COUNTRIES ARE
SUPPORTING YOU, IT MATTERS AND
HELPS IN TERMS OF HOW IT'S GOING
TO BE PERCEIVED GLOBALLY.
>> Brian: IF THE PRESIDENT
DOES NOT DO SOMETHING, HE WILL
NEVER RECOVER CREDIBILITY.
THIS MAKES PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
MOVE TO NOT ENFORCE HIS REDLINE
LOOK TRIVIAL.
>> Greg: LAST WORD, GERALDO.
>> Geraldo: POMPEO WILL NOT
NEGATE THE IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL.
HE WILL MAKE IT TOUGHER PERHAPS.
HE WILL SUGGEST THAT IT BE
TOUGHER BUT HE WILL NOT ADVOCATE